you know what we should try an
icebreaker we know you're busy with your
clothing company V's four hearts but
we've got a serious question to ask you
why is it that mal can use magic but you
can't sure mouths parents are a lot more
magical than your own that doesn't do
your mama have special abilities too she
could turn herself into a mean old witch
in the blink of an eye and brew
poisonous apples like it's nobody's
business so what's up with that Evie now
might be the most powerful person in
auradon but that shouldn't stop others
from using magic to Evie's heritage is
magical so where are her powers and why
isn't she using them watch until the end
to find out why being friends with now
prevents Edie from having powers I think
you're gonna stand up for the food case
[Music]
but instead you lied to them we may call
her the Evil Queen but Evie from
Disney's descendants calls her mom she's
everything a mother isn't supposed to be
but Evie loves her just the same in the
end the Evil Queen just wants what's
best for her daughter and herself she
wants to live in a glorious castle and
have riches beyond her wildest dreams
the Evil Queen might seem a little
powerless on the Isle but she's one of
the most well-known Disney villains of
all time and just like Maleficent the
Evil Queen has some powers of her own
she can cast spells using dark magic in
witchcraft but when it comes to her
daughter Evie it would appear that she
didn't inherit her mother's abilities
but that's not to say that Evie doesn't
have any special abilities of her own we
all know that Evie is a wicked fashion
designer and to makeup artists my mom
taught me how to apply blush before I
could talk but her skills don't end
there she has enhanced intellect and a
knack for chemistry meaning that she
could learn to brew potions if she
wanted to Evie didn't get a chance to
practice magic on the Isle but neither
did mal and she went on to cast plenty
of cells since Evie has a magical
parents many find a bizarre that she
never joined forces with MAO to beat a
common enemy now did this with uma in
descendants three but surely Evie could
have helped her friend out
anyone who has read The Descendants
novels or watched the animated short
series wicked world knows that Eevee
does indeed have magical powers
in fact Eevee goes as far as to call
herself a witch in the books much like
Mao Eevee memorizes her mother's spell
book and puts her magic to good use
but for some reason Eevee didn't have
any powers in The Descendants movies in
descendants wicked world Evie and Mao
accidentally cast a spell together just
like uma and mounted in descendants
three as for Evie's powers it's obvious
that there are some inconsistencies in
the end when it comes to turning books
into movies some things just don't
translate well the United States of
auradon is a magical place so many of
its inhabitants can use magic if they
wish to but that's the problem
a lot of UK's and aks don't want to use
magic when you think about it the only
other --bk who enjoys using their powers
is Uma in the first decent Inns film
Evie had what was left of her mother's
magic mirror and she used it to her
advantage but after getting ratted out
by Chad Evie was nearly expelled she
stopped using magical accessories after
the incident but what about her
natural-born powers it makes total sense
that Carlos and Jade don't have powers
after all Cruella Deville had none of
her own and neither did Jafar but when
it comes to the Evil Queen and her
daughter something just doesn't add up
Evie has so many talents and one of them
is designing clothes she does everything
by hand which must take a lot of time
but if Evie wanted to she could learn
how to use magic to design her outfits
since she was born with a magic touch
learning spells would be a breeze it's
easy for Evie to live without magic
since she grew up without it but it's
almost as if Evie has an aversion to
spells one of the reasons why Evie
doesn't use magic has everything to do
with her status she'd been given a huge
opportunity when she was chosen to
attend our 'adam prep and after
realizing how much auradon meant to her
Evie didn't want to put her new life in
jeopardy but there's a reason why Evie
uses magic in The Descendants novels and
not the
movies and it has to do with now but
before we still all the details it's
worth mentioning that Eevee doesn't love
magic as much as mal does and that has
everything to do with how she was
brought up
whereas Maleficent taught now everything
she needed to know about magic and cells
the Evil Queen focused on beauty and
etiquette Eevee didn't feel the need to
educate herself on magic because she
never thought she would need to use it
her mother hai convinced her that find
yourself a prince with a big castle and
a mother-in-law wig but the real reason
Eevee doesn't have powers in the movies
is because of now the Disney Channel
wanted Mao to be the main protagonist of
the trilogy but to do this many of the
BK's powers had to be dimmed down or
erased this way fans would focus more on
mouths than they did on easy to turn mao
into the franchise's leading lady they
had to strip J Carlos and Evie of their
abilities and that's a wrap on my Eevee
doesn't have any powers if you could
choose a magical ability of your own
what would it be
tell us in the comments thanks for
watching subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to hit that notification
bell so you never miss another video
we'll see you next time
[Music]